antidepressants are more popular than
ever in this country virtually vic wa
tiss according to a CDC report last year
about 1 in 8 Americans reported recent
antidepressant use and yet the nation's
suicide rate has surged and the country
doesn't seem to be that much happier
than countries that have far fewer drugs
in circulation that raises the question
are we thinking about depression in the
wrong way Johann Hari is the author of
lost connections uncovering the real
causes of depression and the unexpected
solutions a book that unexpectedly has
become the center of a lot of debates
and they're sold quite well he joins us
in Johan thanks for coming so this book
has been very controversial I think in
the best way in that it's forced a
conversation where there should have
been one years ago but just summarize
for us if you could crisply what is the
case that you're making about
antidepressants yeah most of the book is
not about antidepressants is about why
we're in such pain in the first place
and I think that everyone watching this
show knows that they have natural
physical needs right you need water you
need food you need shelter if I took
them away from you you'd be in real
trouble real fast right yes there's
equally strong evidence but human beings
have natural psychological needs
overwhelming evidence you've got to feel
you belong you've got to feel your life
has meaning and purpose you've got to
feel that people see you and value
you've got to feel that there's a future
that makes sense to you and our cultures
good at lots of things but there's very
strong evidence we've been getting less
and less good at meeting people's deep
underlying psychological needs and that
is one of the key drivers of this
depression and anxiety crisis what we've
been told up to now when I was a
teenager and I went to my doctor in a
real sense of profound pain my doctor
said taught me a totally biological
story about why I was depressed he said
it was just due to a chemical imbalance
in my brain and you know I dragged
myself for 13 years I remained depressed
there are other people who take into the
process who do experience benefit but
one of things that was so striking to me
when I went travelled all over the world
interview the leading experts in the
world about what really causes
depression and anxiety and what really
solves them is that overwhelmingly it's
due to responses it's a response to key
factors in how we're living today I
learned there's scientific evidence just
laughs
because it seems so obvious you know why
have we been telling ourselves that is
some mysterious chemical imbalance those
do exist of course but for the
overwhelming majority maybe it has to it
the way that we're living he's making us
unhappy if you're depressed and anxious
you're not crazy you're not a machine
with broken parts you're a human being
with unmet needs it's like an sound a
bit strange in the abstract so I'll give
you a very obvious example that connects
people immediately there's a study that
asks the average American how many close
friends do you have you could call on in
a crisis and when they started doing it
years ago the most common answer was
five today the most common answer is
none so we none there's no she's not the
average is the most common answer so
we've become the loneliest society
that's ever been and what I wanted to
look at was what are antidepressants for
these nine deep underlying causes of
depression anxiety what are the
solutions to these problems I'll give
you an example to that one there's a
doctor in East London called Sam Evren
Tim had loads of patients coming to him
acutely depressed and anxious and he
felt really uncomfortable because he'd
been told in his training even though he
knew the science was much more
sophisticated to say you've just got a
chemical imbalance in your brain and
just give them drugs like me he's not
opposed to the drugs but he could see
this wasn't solving the problem a lot of
them for example were acutely lonely he
didn't experiment a woman came to good
Lisa Cunningham she'd been shut away in
our home for seven years with really
severe depression and anxiety he said
Lisa I'll keep giving you the drugs
don't worry I'm also going to prescribe
something else I'm going to prescribe
you to take part in a group there was an
area of scrubland behind the doctor's
surgery he said we'll come and support
you but I want you to meet with a group
of depressed and anxious people twice a
week and we're going to turn this into a
beautiful garden they met over weeks and
months as Lisa put it to me as the
garden began to bloom we began to bloom
a study of a very similar program found
it's more than twice as effective as
chemical antidepressants what I learned
all over the world is there are people
who are trying antidepressants that are
about dealing with the deep social and
psychological reasons why we feel so
terrible in the first place so the D
they're much more effective everything
you said is so obvious reports so
completely with our experiences people
and we're out of time but maybe you can
come back and explain why we vest so
much unwarranted faith in psychiatrists
why are we so willing to take a bad
advice from people with
I don't understand we've only given
those psychiatrists one lever to pull so
in one way you can't blame them for
pulling it but what we need to do as a
society is put in place a much much more
expanded menu of options things that
actually deal with these nine deep
reasons why we feel so terrible in the
first place and those options exist
they're being tried all over the world
I've seen them and they are reducing
depression and anxiety leave if you've
got a lot of hope
I believe you completely look there's
lost connections uncovering the real
causes of depression and the unexpected
solutions I'm reading the title so
people will buy it I think it's great
Gohan thank you oh thank you so much